hi how do you feel oh hell no that's
I'm having my friends from Singapore
come over something I will be seeing it
and I'm not sure how they really would
like it or not like it so yeah I'm a
little nervous I think it's a lot more
hands-on definitely there we have a
similar course packet as utd where it's
called um studies but I think that's a
more film related module this this feels
a lot more like a good good mix between
education of education and entertainment
so as in its really really nice to see
like all this stuff that you're not that
you always want to do or you always see
around and see so many people making
YouTube videos and you're like kind of
learning the theory behind it all and
you saw is justice or let's just set up
a camera and just put it on but there is
actually a lot more going into it and
yeah I probably that's what's the
difference between all the good videos
you see and some people just teaching
how to derive some equations on a
blackboard I guess yeah i think the
small class size really really helps and
the fact that we just help each other we
give each other feedback you dumb in the
conventional way would just be submitted
your turn in your ideas and one teacher
maybe two teachers are just created but
this and this you get a whole class fit
the host classes feedback which is a lot
more useful i think it may be a bit hard
because make things people may not be
able to jail that wells we were too
comfortable to kiss comment too much
comment oh yeah thank you